we take um technology for granted um
when we work in the tech space
we think that the things that you know
you don't even think about um so one of
the first lessons for me
um when when we started this training
women in in in digital
was how women were so surprised that
there's quite a huge online community
that
they could reach their customers online
and i remember one lady saying oh i
thought you know it's just kids playing
on their phones
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl and in media
partnership with c-tec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm joined by nobukosi
germany founder of bahati tech a cyber
security and data protection company
with headquarters in cape town south
africa she is also the founder and
executive director of the gift
foundation which is a non-profit
organization focused on assisting rural
and informal settlement based young
women to acquire technical and digital
skills to improve their livelihoods and
break the cycle of poverty
novukosi germany welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from cape town how
are you i'm good and how are you michael
i'm doing great thank you for being here
i love the impact that you're having on
your community on the tech world
especially in the area that you're in
and and i'm excited to hear about your
journey in a more intimate way and hear
about the challenges and the and the way
the ways that you're tackling them and
how through tech and through innovation
you're helping mitigate
some some inequalities that that you
observe around you and so nubukosi tell
me a little bit about your own journey
and and what what kinds of things have
you been involved with
um well firstly thank you so much for
for having me on your show um so
i've worked in tech for
a number of years i was working in
corporates previously
after studying computer science
and then
started my company bahati tech about
four years ago four to five years ago
and it's sort of
you would know when you start a company
you have one idea of what it's going to
be and then as you go it sort of pivots
and it becomes its own thing
um so
it's finally become
a company where we just focusing on
cyber and privacy
started off just doing um
services training consulting and so on
but now we're actually building software
platforms to automate some of the
processes around privacy management risk
management especially trying to help
companies mitigate risk of ransomware
and things like that
um so that's quite um exciting projects
that we're busy with inside the company
and because i've always
yeah no i think it's it's it's it's
needed um all over the world um for us
to really um come up with different
ideas of how
um we can help um create a safer
cyberspace
and now
cyber is not in building companies and
suburbs and the only thing that you're
involved with you're actually also
pretty pretty highly involved with
with women in tech right
that's correct so because i was always
um
um involved in tech even before
going into business um i started
receiving a lot of requests from women
you know asking for mentorship for
support um so we started a foundation
called the gif foundation to
mentor and train girls um and young
women who um
living in communities where they haven't
had opportunities to get into the tech
industry to train them and upskill them
so that they can
be able to access careers in tech
and it's it's been really an exciting
journey because it's grown quite rapidly
um and with the pandemic
when it hit
we saw that there was a huge need for us
to support small business
and we've
been working with especially women based
in rural areas who are running
traditional non-tech enabled businesses
um who because of you know the the
strict regulations around social
distancing and covert couldn't continue
operating their businesses you know like
if you have your moms and pups shop at
the corner store or
women in whatever retail or
manufacturing business um so we help
them to actually use technology to pivot
and start trading online and you know
just um
transforming their business to become
tech enabled end to end from from
marketing sales right to fulfillment um
and we've been able to train about 120
people
120 businesses
which has really helped them to survive
you know the pandemic as you probably
know i think all over the world small
businesses are the ones who are most
severely affected and
in many instances they are the ones who
don't get a lot of support or can't
access the reports yeah
right now tell me a little bit more
about what you learned
you know working with these different
programs whether it's the gifts program
or or the pilot that you did with with
women in coding and what are some things
that you've learned throughout your
career that your things are not trivial
i think um we take technology for
granted um when we work in the tech
space
we think that the things that you know
you don't even think about um so one of
the first lessons for me
um when when we started this training
women in in digital
was how women were so surprised that
there's quite a huge online community
that
they could reach their customers online
and i remember one lady saying oh i
thought you know it's just kids playing
on their phones i didn't realize i could
actually reach people um
i've been busy like
printing posters and handing out
pamphlets
to try and
market my business when i could have
been doing a lot more effective work
online
and i thought that's odd but actually
if you've never been exposed to that
culture you just don't know that
there's a whole community of people that
you can reach to grow um your brand to
get exposure on the internet
right tell me a little bit more about
you know cape town right now the tech
scene what's happening there and
and how you find yourself within this
tech scene
so cape town is it's probably one of the
bigger hubs in terms of um the tech
scene there's quite a big tech community
a lot of startups
um so it's quite busy in that regard and
it was definitely that way before um
covert we'll have to see um what happens
when people get together again and um
but my
my impression is that it's probably
going to grow even more
so
there's a lot of young people especially
um
people coming straight out of varsity
and going straight into startups
so even the local universities which i
think is great um uh are creating that
culture of innovation
and building startups um while people
are still on campus doing their
undergrads
which is what i think will help us to
grow a community because i think you
really need to have a strong community
to build
um strong businesses
and also we're getting a lot of um
vcs um that are starting in in the space
um a lot of angel investors um uh are
active in cape town so it's quite an
exciting space to be in at the moment
right now
do you feel that the spaces
has changed in the recent years it's
it's
you know is it specifically you know in
the last few years is this more of a
linear growth that you've been observing
since you've founded
your own companies in your own
organizations
where can we see this thing going
i think um
people are tackling different kinds of
of of problems um and also with um you
know
one of the side effects um maybe
unintended consequences of the pandemic
is um people are collaborating a lot
more across countries um because
everyone is working virtually now so you
don't have to
um travel to silicon valley to interact
with people who are
in the tech industry so
um we've we've seen a lot of um local
startups for example get funded by
um you know vcs from the bay area so
it's it's quite exciting in that regard
um where you know like um you know what
is a border
at this at this stage
um so it's growing but i think it's also
becoming a lot more diverse a lot more
women are stepping up um and actually
bringing out their own innovations which
is which is great because i think um
that's what we need we need we need
diversity in solving the problems that
we have and
mostly women are the ones who experience
the challenges so they know
which solutions work best
100 tell me a little bit more about your
own journey going to study computer
science and then deciding to take a more
active part in your community rather
than just working in a corporate you
have working corporates but but then
you've just had to actually take a more
active part in the day-to-day and the
hands-on
[Music]
so when i when i was studying computer
science to be honest i i didn't know
where it would take me you know it's
it's one of those things where
you know you're just studying something
and um
because i had not been exposed to
anybody who was
in computer science before arriving at
varsity so it took a while for me to
understand
what you can actually do with the in
this kind of field
um but i think it's
what made you decide to go study
computer science in the first place
i think i was sort of um
persuaded
to to choose that option um because um
in the country there was a huge um shift
where people were encouraging people who
studied math and science
or who are good at math and science to
actually take technology or engineering
subjects
and if it weren't for that i would have
probably studied english literature or
something
like that um um but you know because of
of my high school results i ended up you
know in the science faculty
um studying computer science yeah
were you surprised by the field and and
what you learned from it through a
university that you didn't know before
because it's not that usual that
somebody goes and out of the blue just
decides to go study computer science
especially if they didn't grow up in an
environment that fosters
curiosities surrounding technology and
and what computer science is about
definitely i mean i remember um when i
first
started um or when i signed that decided
i'm going to sign up for it i thought
while it's computers it's probably a lot
of video games you know it can't be that
bad you know
and it was totally different so
um but one of the things that i think
helped me um
uh
my grandmother um who wasn't um
highly educated but she was very
inquisitive used to ask me like every
time i went home for holidays like what
are you studying and i would say i'll
try to explain to um it's computer
science but you know she'd be like but
what is it
um so i got to really
um practice explaining really technical
concepts um in a way that you know the
average person can can grasp it and i
think that's where
the love for explaining tech and
simplifying
complex
terminology and concepts came from
do you think that this
practice and this skill that you've
harnessed
with your grandmother did this skill
play out while you were building your
foundations to help women get into tech
and empower them
i think it's it's helped to
become less intimidating
because you know to be honest there's a
lot of training out there um and you
have to ask yourself you know why why
don't people take it up
and i think people sometimes feel
intimidated
because of the language that we use in
the industry
or
where we pitch things that are supposed
to be entry level
um so
one of the things that we really focus
on in the foundation is to really make
it accessible
um use really simple language because
there's no there's no reason to speak in
complex terminology and to use jargon if
your audience is is being left behind so
i think that's that's one of the things
that have made our training programs
quite successful
now if you're looking you know more
towards the future with everything that
you know now about computer science and
about your own community and and an
impact where do you see your trajectory
take you if you had to play a simulation
of going
you know 10 15 years down the line so
well firstly in the foundation i'm
working to grow it to become less and
less dependent on me
um so to put people
who can be able to take it forward and
to see myself playing less of an
operational role
and that's really where
i'd like to go in the foundation but i'm
quite excited with the opportunities
that exist in in cyber
and the work that we're doing um
and
the the the stuff that is coming up
especially a lot of young people that
are coming up in the in the company um
so we have a lot of um
ideas and dreams of where we can take
that
um and and um
you know we're looking at the north
american market because in tech if you
if you win everywhere in the world but
you don't win in america you haven't won
if you win in america and at least today
maybe that will change one day but at
least today that's not true yes it's
still it's still the case yeah yeah
so so these are some of our
short to medium term goal but definitely
in the foundation we have very
aggressive goals to
empower
a lot of of girls and women because the
gender gap
is quite huge and there's a lot of work
to be done
um and we're trying to ramp that up
really quickly and get a lot of people
on board to carry out um the programs
that we're doing
what is the biggest challenge that you
have
in scaling this that you're observing
so when the the women that we work with
um are rural based women
so um and we we quite based in the city
so there's a lot of um
um logistics challenges in in accessing
them
um so we work a lot with ngos or
organizations that are local
and so we have to build those
relationships and those partnerships
right so sometimes we can't move as fast
as we would like to move we have to
um you know
go with somebody who's local so that
people don't
um feel you know who are these people um
coming here so we always have to partner
with um someone else
um and also just being an ngo there's
always the continuous fundraising of
course um
getting support for for the programs
yeah
definitely now i want you to take a to
take me back a little bit to your
childhood and you know before computer
science you know before
thinking about english literature what
really fascinates you as a kid as you're
going through life what really sparks
your curiosity in the day-to-day
i was i was one of those kids who was
like really a bookworm
um so i love reading and i love
daydreaming um
and you know imagining you know things
that um i don't know if children
nowadays read as much as we did i think
maybe they spend a lot more time on
gadgets
um but
reading instagram stories instead of
books
yeah i mean i'm not saying we were
better or for worse offer you know um
but um that's probably um one of the
things we
looking back i think i never had a
problem with imagining
what what life could be like or it could
be different because i just grew up
um you know having these daydreams and
and and reading about things that are
totally firing and you know accepting
that they are normal and
achievable so
um
it's probably helped me to um be able to
um create for myself a a different life
from the one that i was accustomed to
and if you look at your day today right
now what are some things that inspire
you either a specific occurrence
or just general day-to-day things
so um
you know it's it nowadays you know
there's so many challenges everywhere in
the world that you look and
um a lot of of of problems that um if
you're an entrepreneur and i think an
entrepreneur is is first and foremost a
problem solver
and so you know always identifying
challenges or problems and we just like
um what can we do what what what what
what how can we solve this issue
um one of the biggest challenges we have
in south africa is high youth
unemployment
um so that is one of the things that i'm
really passionate about addressing
um and i think that technology um has a
huge role to play you know um skills
empowerment
um
is is is one way of of helping people
overcome
those challenges and become employable
because
we do have high high youth unemployment
but also we have a lot of industries
um where people say there are no skilled
people so
the the solution would seem we need to
skill to upskill people
right
and so if you're looking now on your
journey and the people that know you and
you know the way that you think about
yourself what are some words that you
would use to describe
you know your journey either you know
personally or professionally
oh that's quite an interesting question
um
i would say um
probably um a lot of of of tenacity
and because it's it's not it's not an
easy journey you know to go into
business
or especially in the tech space um um
you know it can be intimidating
sometimes but you know you you have to
have a lot of tenacity a lot of grit
um and a lot of courage i would say
100 100 percent
thank you so much for uh joining me here
this 20 minutes i learned a lot again a
lot of inspiration and i think that you
know the journey that you're on is
incredible and obviously the impact that
you're having is great
and i and i'm very thankful for
everything that i learned and for your
time so thank you very much and stay
safe and stay healthy
[Music]